what's up guys we're from finiti so if
it's 600 k subscribers which is really
amazing because we only hit 500 less
than month ago and for the special
episode we are playing or wrong hand
Solomons let's find out who wins it's
gonna be me guess the hand
I'll start love oh please play oh no my
papa technique is beautifully cut
doesn't have a back end yes you know I
just don't need it I'm playing full hand
on table one one great placement
even better than with the left time
three two
[Music]
Oh No
there oh good one
and I was a horrible server that was my
special sub I'm not gonna use again ah
[Music]
laughing I might take me oh no it looks
really good thanks I'm just not very
good am I
you're good but that's just better
Oh
this is embarrassingly bad 94
you push to the back line nice and a
great backhand to follow up for great
match do you want to start I'll get I'll
let you start
I feel I can be anybody West as a couch
or up top screen I don't know what you
call that
[Music]
now I
[Music]
they're always outside you're supposed
to it Oh what's in it
oh good stuff good it's sir just going
to fight me no no no back ends don't
play back end
I
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh really good save I mean I could have
taken it back on are you taking it like
[Music]
there that's a good tactic that's the
combo
ah
[Music]
oh it's ain't it it's getting close
[Music]
how can I miss that nine eight
[Music]
haha
[Music]
Oh
that was from the biggest point of my
life prosecutor alley you need a break
after that exactly play sorry sir no
thank you
ok 0 0 ml to serve I'm no other option
than to beat other latte is this
obstacle
sorry lucky
no bad actually not bad good placement
now there was a big boy come here yeah
oh wow that's the big part I was talking
about what that doesn't even look like
he's playing with his wrong hand I'll
give you a point for that sorry but that
that was so difficult
I want to be back hand by one
[Music]
nothing's going in anymore but those
looking strong
oh okay mr. 6-4 look at that oh what a
tactic six-six good comeback
[Music]
ha ha ha
boom 7/7
almost
[Music]
good swing on that
whoa whoa whoa aha
[Applause]
yeah come on you go arrogant enough to
the one good shot I always do
so close
[Music]
I have to get a nice finish
I think I can take the replay the ball
was out and we checked it for your time
points Samuel
Oh
[Music]
almost
[Music]
oh no I missed it
not now I'm playing safe yeah
[Applause]
he just doesn't want to win it now he's
my best serve coming
[Music]
Oh No
goodbye it's goodbye let us know in the
comments what kind of tournament you
want to see next
also hit subscribe and check out
previous videos there until next time